conspiracy theories have been around for
centuries
in fact many historians believe that the
American Declaration of Independence was
created in response to a potential
British plot that actually didn't exist
and while you may not think that you
believe in any conspiracy theories they
follow such an affective cognitive
formula that you might believe in one
right now without even realizing it
sources are shocking footage has emerged
of Justin Bieber that appears to show
transform into a giant lizard boom
studies have found that actually over
50% of Americans believe in at least one
conspiracy theory YouTube and other
social media platforms have come under a
lot of fire for conspiracy theory
content proliferation online so we
wanted to investigate two things one
whether or not there has been a
measurable rise in conspiracy theories
in recent years and to how conspiracy
theories work to manipulate your brain
so you can better defend yourself
against their tactics and ultimately
find out what it means if you believe in
one in the first place
from an evolutionary perspective
biologists hypothesized that we've been
programmed to fall for conspiracy
theories as a protective measure as
hunter-gatherers violence was a common
cause for danger and so being able to
identify conspirators became an
evolutionary advantage this theory was
eventually developed into something that
smart academics refer to as the adaptive
conspiracism hypothesis the hypothesis
is essentially this if you're walking in
the jungle and you see a snake but it's
actually just a stick okay that's
embarrassing but you're still alive
to you but if you're walking in the
jungle and you see a stick no biggie
but it's actually a snake okay oops you
step on it it's nice you now you're dead
this explains how our brains have been
programmed into thinking better safe
than sorry when it comes to survival in
short we fall for conspiracy theories
because they seem like the safer option
it feels a lot better to be prepared for
an enemy attack that might not even be
there than to not be prepared at all
this brings us to a pattern found in
many conspiracy theories that makes them
so effective and it's called the
illusory pattern perception the illusory
pattern perception is a cognitive bias
we humans have evolved we tend to notice
patterns within random stimuli in order
to create conceptual meaning behind the
world we live in
let's take a simple example of this
scenario if you flipped a coin three
times and each time you got heads what
do you think would happen next if you're
unlikely to fall victim to the illusory
pattern perception of conspiracy
theories you'd see there was always a
50/50 chance that you get either heads
or tails because obviously the flips you
got before have no impact on the flip
you get next but others who are more
prone to illusory pattern perception
well think they're more likely get tails
as three heads in a row that's insane it
has to be tails next they're noticing a
pattern and creating a meaning behind it
we were deeply entertained by Shane
Dawson's conspiracy theory videos they
made us lul and the music was extremely
effective it's like move over Hans
Zimmer there's a new gun in town
when we started to apply our research to
Shane's videos whether he intended it or
not we could see the illusory pattern
perception he establishes a pattern and
then directly correlates it to something
bigger
for example while at Chucky Cheese they
noticed that some of the pizza slices
aren't lining up perfectly and then
start to think that maybe there are old
recycled pieces pictures of the pieces
that don't fit together that's pretty
crazy they then see another piece of the
pattern an employee who's looking at an
old pizza to see whether or not it's
good enough to recycle again these are
just pieces of information that are
strung together to form a theory that's
not necessarily substantiated even
though there's no solid evidence it's
really entertaining and really enticing
but what's most interesting is that some
people might be more convinced based on
their biology being vulnerable to
conspiracy theories has been directly
linked to dopamine in your brain in one
study after participants were given a
drug to increase dopamine levels they
were more likely to exhibit the illusory
pattern perception another study showed
that people with genetically higher
levels of free dopamine in their brains
were more likely to believe in one or
more conspiracy theories on top of this
if you have feelings of anxiety
uncertainty or powerlessness it can
encourage you to search for order within
chaos one study showed participants
paintings that were very orderly by
Victor Vasarely
and paintings with a lot of disorder by
Jackson Pollock the participants were
then asked to look for patterns
everybody was able to see patterns in
the order leave a Sara Lee paintings but
those who found more pattern in the
disorder Jackson Pollock's were also
more likely to believe in conspiracy
theories just to be clear falling for
conspiracy theories does not mean that
you are stupid as humans we are
brilliant smart animals like for example
if I ever need an ego boost I just go up
to my dog and I'm like literally
compared to me you're so dumb but our
brains are susceptible and this is why
we need to be talking about why
conspiracy theories may be damaging our
society studies show that right now 30
7% of Americans believe in the
conspiracy theory that global warming is
a hoax of course the scientific
consensus is that not only does it exist
but it's having an immense impact on our
environment and our economy as well as
displacing and killing people 20% of
Americans still believe the conspiracy
theory that vaccines cause autism this
one has been extremely rampant on
YouTube Facebook and Pinterest and has
been helped by celebrities like Charlie
Sheen and Kristin Cavallari not sure if
it's smart to be taking medical advice
about safety from someone who casually
walks in the middle of the street
science again proves that vaccines are
one of the most effective ways to
prevent disease and the proliferation of
these vaccine hesitancy conspiracy
theories online are the reason that
musil's are now having new outbreaks all
over America in the world and also the
w-h-o claims that vaccine hesitancy is
the third large threat to global health
this year where this all comes to head
is the proliferation of conspiracy
theories by algorithms like our favorite
notorious and elusive YouTube algorithm
we're talking to you right now in a
platform that is controlled by an
algorithm designed to keep you here
longer and have you enjoying everything
you consume so you can bet that if you
watch a video that's an hour long about
conspiracy theories it's gonna know and
think you like that and start suggesting
stuff to you but it's not likely to be
the overly pedantic or nuanced or calm
videos but rather the really emotionally
intense and stuff that you know might
contain this information combined the
technological algorithm with your brainy
biological algorithm and you can see why
YouTube has a problem on their hands
former YouTube software engineer
Guillaume Joslin started to speak about
how YouTube would actually target
vulnerable people to show them
conspiracy theory videos to keep them on
the platform for longer he even created
a website called algo transparency that
you can go on right now and what it does
is it shows you the top YouTube channels
and the videos that they are currently
recommending while we were researching
this video at the current time we went
on the website and the top four videos
being recommended had to do with
conspiracy theories or secret in firm
you can go check out right now like it
will be different it's very interesting
to sort of like just keep up and check
out what it is that YouTube is
suggesting to the world right now but
interestingly scholars have actually
studied the prevalence of conspiracy
theories through the years and it
actually remains pretty consistent they
do have our say that the Internet has
displaced the gatekeepers the producers
editors and scholars who decide what is
worthy of dissemination this has caused
YouTube and other platforms to start
actually taking action like Pinterest
has actually banned all conversations
about vaccines until they can figure out
how to manage and stop the spread of
misinformation and YouTube doesn't take
down the videos as of now but they do D
monetize anti-vaxxer YouTube has also
started putting little Wikipedia blurbs
underneath videos that may contain
misinformation and they claim to be
reducing recommendations of borderline
content so now you know from an
evolutionary perspective why we might
fall for conspiracy theories and the
common cognitive formula that makes them
work so well and lastly why from a
biological perspective you might be more
susceptible you can check out our
podcast for more information about
conspiracy theories because it's where I
found out that Mitch was obsessed with
them growing I yeah growing up I used to
love a lot of conspiracy theories I
named uh some of them in the podcast so
you listen to that I think our Halloween
is dead and been replaced by snot body
devil so check over there and we'll put
some links in the description otherwise
subscribe and we'll be back next time
for a new video see ya